there's nothing on TV quite like Adult
Swim's the Eric Andre show when it comes
together it's a messy and hilarious
package of free forms a meanness it
takes a lot of work to put such a unique
and original program together which
means there's no shortage of wild
behind-the-scenes stories a television
show makes it to the air after its
creators and producers follow a very
specific process a writer comes up with
a script or outline convinces an agent
it's a bankable concept and then the
agent pitches it to a network or
production company if all goes well
executives will ask for a script and
then use it as the basis for an
introductory or a pilot episode if they
like that more episodes get ordered this
is not how the Eric Andre show made it
to Adult Swim Andre told spin I knew it
was too crazy and visual and too much
like an absurdist
stream-of-consciousness show to really
sell on paper so instead of writing a
script and essentially begging someone
to pay for him to make a pilot of it he
skipped some steps and made a
proof-of-concept episode on his own and
on the cheap he explained we rented out
this little semi abandoned semi illegal
bodega in the middle of Brooklyn we just
cleaned it up a little bit threw up
curtains after compiling the footage
Andre further cut costs by learning the
editing program final cuts and cutting
together the pilot himself the project
took about a year ran after multiple
networks quote thought it sucked he
found an ally an Adult Swim the Eric
Andre show is one of the more original
shows to hit TV in recent years but it
didn't emerge in a vacuum Eric Andre's
influences include sketch comedy Adult
Swim pioneers in 70s television he tells
the Huffington Post
it's basically like Space Ghost as a
live-action show Space Ghost Coast to
Coast was a 1994 to 2008 talk show in
which animated reimagined superhero
Space Ghost interviewed confused
celebrities from his galactic lair Andre
says his show also contains DNA from the
Tom Green show Sacha Baron Cohen's
reality blurring - Ollie G show and the
syndicated purposely cheap-looking 1970s
talk show parody Fernwood tonight other
shows from which andre found inspiration
include jackass and Chappelle's Show for
its quick sketch format the Eric Andre
show may be a deconstructed talk show
but it's a talk show nonetheless host
Eric Andre knew we wanted a sidekick the
way Johnny Carson could play off Ed
McMahon or Conan O'Brien and Andy
Richter he told The Huffington Post I
knew I was so crazy
I needed somebody justice out there
comedic Lee but opposite in energy to be
the voice of reason so he turned to
someone who ran in the same New York
stand-up comedy circles Hannibal Buress
who had yet to achieve household name
status from a growing resume that
included stints as a Saturday Night Live
Rider and a broad city cast member Andre
felt that Buress who exudes a calm
mellow persona was perfect my seat feels
like like it's alive or something you
know we got snakes would human traits
Andre also appreciates and is keenly
aware of how his show is one of the few
on TV with two african-american leads he
told the fader I want to prove to
America that black people are the most
diverse creative group of people and we
can express any way we want we're both
very different and we both also somehow
connect on a certain level and we both
kind of have our own unique point of
view and it's fun to show people new and
unique black perspectives I did not get
the job at Fruit Loops
my body is now your communion please eat
from me as a cable programming block
that airs only at night Adult Swim isn't
bound by the same constraints as other
television enterprises its programming
tends to be more edgy envelope-pushing
or straight-up weird as evidenced by
hits like Rick and Morty Tim and Eric
awesome show great job and the Eric
Andre show but while it's stable of
talents has lots of freedom to follow
their warped creative visions Adult Swim
is still a television network that can
survive only as long as it doesn't
alienate advertisers or push away too
many viewers the network's standard and
practices Department plays just a few
limitations on Andre he explained the
arrangement to spin that certain kinds
of self-harm and drug use and making fun
of specific gods are like the 3sp issues
that come up under the heading of
religious mockery Andre says he's
allowed to curse the heavens and
challenge the almighty to strike him
with lightning but if he added the word
Jesus to the bit that would get axed
have you seen my dog
the Eric Andre show also incorporates
public corrala style comedy caught on
tape we're planning isn't really a
possibility and things can go very wrong
very quickly andre explained in his
interview with the huffington post all
the bits where i thought i was
definitely going to get assaulted i
didn't and then the bit that i thought
would be the least violent was the most
that event would be the time he quote
got beat up at a Mensa convention audrey
tried to crash a meeting of the
organization for the super-intelligent
while wearing a suit of armor all while
claiming to have an IQ of 400 after
being thoroughly manhandled and forced
out of the building by a pushy Mensa
member andre voluntarily fled before
security guards arrived the natural
reaction to adres antics isn't always
violence derision and hostility on one
occasion random strangers felt sorry for
him andre related one such story on
Speak Easy I did a bit where I dressed
up like a cop and we went up to Harlem
and a handcuffed myself around a light
post and dropped my pants before anybody
showed up and I was going ah could
somebody help me and all these people
gathered and they're like how did you
get in that situation I'm like it's a
long story just please help me out
Andre fondly recalled how quote the
community came together to help him get
uncuffed in his pants back home if
anyone ever thought the pranks pulled on
an unknowing and unwitting public
throughout the run of the Eric Andre
show were less than authentic this story
about Andre facing legal consequences
and experiencing the temporary loss of
his personal freedom should dispel that
notion while filming a bit for the first
season of the show
Andre quote crashed the town hall
meeting where the mayor was speaking he
explained to the fader vote for me for
class president and I'll put beer in the
water fountains and cameras in the girls
locker rooms as it was an official town
meeting in the town of Rancho Cucamonga
California the place was full of law
enforcement personnel who acted quickly
he further related to the fader they
escorted me out and I was like don't
taze me bro I also told a cop my name
was John Coltrane they believed him
apparently having never heard of the
famous jazz musician whose name Andre
nicked
nevertheless the sheriff's eventually
took Andre to the local jail where he
had dispensed of time explaining just
for the night but I had to go to courts
and get a lawyer
very expensive
concurrent was starring on the early
seasons of the Eric Andre show Eric
Andre moonlighted with the supporting
role on the dark ABC sitcom don't trust
the B in apartment 23
well definitely one of the edgier shows
on a broadcast network schedule it was
still a sitcom airing in primetime on a
channel owned by Walt Disney according
to an Andre interview with The
Huffington Post some executives at ABC
were at best tentative about his bizarre
Adult Swim series and quote not thrilled
at worst when he tried to include don't
trust the B in apartment 23 on press
releases for the Eric Andre show the
network intervened as he explained it
and then like 14 people from ABC flew in
on helicopters were like don't mention
us in the Adult Swim show the extreme
nature of the Eric Andre show means pain
and injury is a possibility if not a
probability for its host one of the
series signature pits finds Andre
jumping through walls and destroying his
desk at the top of every episode in here
well the chance of serious bodily damage
there is limited because the production
makes the furniture thin and easily
breakable Andre has still gotten himself
seriously hurt during both in studio
bits and in out in the world film stunts
he aggravated a pre-existing injury when
he tried to lift co-host Hannibal
furnaces chair he explained the injury
to spend it was way heavier than I
anticipated and I tore my back in half I
had to like marine crawl back to the
video monitors and take a 20-minute
break oh my god
his most painful scrape long-term knee
damage came as the result of a bit where
he hid in a garbage can so as the hop
out and scared people who walked by he
said I'm in physical therapy for my
knees are both out of the track most
notably however was the mysterious
injury Andre sustained to one of his
buttocks which Andre explained
matter-of-factly I took a whole out of
my butt sheet I don't remember when or
how it happened but I just went home and
it looked like someone had held a
cigarette against my butt cheek and just
kept going the talkshow elements of the
Eric Andre show only resembles something
like The Tonight Show on the surface
there's a desk in chairs a suited host
the sidekick and famous guests but this
program doesn't exist the fallen over
celebrities and let them promote their
latest projects the Eric Andre show sets
out to make its guests deeply unsettled
really having a tough time manner of
young people it's very hard for me yeah
Andre told split cider it's fun to see
guests out of their comfort zones we
just figured out different ways to
psychologically torture the guests among
the things that different celebrities
endured without knowing about it ahead
of time water slowly dripping on them
mild electric shock and rotten clams
placed under their seats when clueless
star Stacey - guest the swarm of rats
came out to kiss her feet seemingly
knowing what they might face went
booking an appearance on the Eric Andre
show most celebrities just roll with it
others however have bailed after Andre
drew a historically offensive symbol on
his forehead and pretended to eat
regurgitated food the hillstar Lauren
Conrad walked right off the set reberty
I cut off his stint on the program on
Andre produced a prosthetic male organ
and brought a cap undressed man out on
stage look at don't you touch me male
the vast majority of TV shows air one
season per year in successive years
turning out a batch of episodes every
fall the Eric Andre show doesn't work on
such a mainstream or tight timeframe and
it never has
according to Hannibal Buress the show's
pilot came together in 2008 in 2009 all
Adult Swim didn't announce that it
picked up the show and placed it on its
schedule until May 2012 debuting it on
air that same month fans had to wait
nearly a year and a half for season two
which didn't arrive until October 2013
season 3 dutifully followed about a year
later toward the end of 2014 but then
another extremely long wait ensued for
season 4 finally reaching the airwaves
in the summer of 2016
true to form the Eric Andre show also
made fans wait for a fifth season in
October 2000 19 Entertainment Weekly
broke the news that Andre Buress and
their disintegrating set will come back
to television sometime in 2020 but win
exactly for the Adult Swim Twitter
account it will be quotes late in the
year check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you